(audience cheering)
- Say hi to Taylor.
- The winner.
The winner.
- I know.
- The winner. The winner.
- Of "American Idol" is-
- The winner.
- He's literally only said
that to so many people.
We're two of 'em.
That's so cool.
(Ryan laughing)
- Great to see you guys.
- I found out something
new that I did not know.
I didn't know that you were originally...
They maybe almost had you as a judge?
- Yeah, originally when the
producers, Nigel and Ken-
- Yeah.
- Were setting up the show,
they had heard me on the
radio here in Los Angeles
and they thought that
I might fit the panel
to be up there with whoever
else was already on.
- Yeah.
- I guess Simon
was already on board
and I don't know who else at that point.
And I was like, "Well wait a minute.
I would love to audition to be the host."
And so I auditioned
eventually to be the host-
- Yeah.
- And I got the job.
So I'm happy to still have the job.
- I know, that's incredible.
I just, I was like,
(audience cheering)
what would it be like if you initially
were one of the judges?
- See, the problem is
I'm like in auto host mode all the time
so I don't know that I'd be
able to sit behind the desk
and just give feedback.
I'd want to do that,
then toss to commercial.
Welcome back. How are you?
(Kelly laughing)
You know, all the...
And that would be too much.
- Are you like this in life?
Like when you're with family-
- Kelly Clarkson.
- Or like on a date, you're
just like, "Wait, I'm sorry,
I'm trying not to-"
- On a date,
"Good evening. How are you?"
- Yeah. (laughing)
- We would like to have
the nachos followed by...
I think, would you like the fajitas?
- I just mean-
- Matter of fact,
let's have the beef and chicken fajitas
and we'll be right back
after we use the bathroom.
(Kelly and audience laughing)